كان ذلك المساء
قاسيًا ، أعني أنني أصبت بحمى منخفضة الدرجة
وإرهاق
وقشعريرة يصف ياسر بتولفي
الآثار الجانبية التي عانى منها
أثناء تجربة لقاح فيروس كوفيد الحديثة
بعد 30 دقيقة ، وكان لدي القليل من
تصلب
في عضلات ذراعي اليسرى مثلك.
لقد تعرضت لكمات في ذراعك بشكل أساسي
عندما تمر بهذه العملية برمتها ،
استمارة موافقة صفحة ياسر 22 تسمع عن جميع
الآثار الجانبية المحتملة
مع العلم أنك تجرب شيئًا
تعرف أنه ليس لدينا الكثير من
البيانات في  في
الوقت الذي راودتك فيه أي أفكار ثانية قبل أن
تأخذ الأمر بصدق ، سانجاي ،
نعم ، تدعي أن كل
قرار نتخذه
هو المخاطرة مقابل المكافأة ، وعندما
أعلنت الشركة عن بيانات مبكرة
تظهر أكثر من 94 فعالية ، كان ياسر
واثقًا من أنها تستحق العناء.
تدوم طويلاً واحتمالية
عدم حصول الأشخاص على هذا اللقاح
وإصابة الأشخاص بفيروس كورونا فعليًا ، حيث تستمر
هذه التأثيرات لفترة أطول
ويمكن أن تكون حياة أو موتًا.
أيام arly
، واثنين من المتسابقين الرئيسيين للقاح في
هذا البلد ، تستخدم شركة pfizer و moderna
نوعًا من التسلسل الجيني يسمى
mrna ،
إنها تقنية لم
يتم استخدامها من قبل في البشر
خارج التجارب السريرية.
البروتين
الذي تريده
في هذه الحالة ، البروتين الشائك الذي
يستخدمه الفيروس للدخول إلى خلايانا ،
تتطلب هذه اللقاحات جرعتين ، واحدة لتستمر في تناول جرعة واحدة ،
بحيث يتم تعزيزها لبضعة أسابيع حتى
يتصاعد الجسم ما نأمل
أن يكون استجابة مناعية دائمة واحدة
من أكبر المخاوف
الآن  هي أن الآثار الجانبية التي
يصفها ياسر
التعب وألم العضلات والحمى والقشعريرة
ستمنع الناس من الحصول على
الجرعة الثانية ،
ربما 10 15 بالمائة من الأشخاص الذين تم
تحصينهم
لديهم آثار جانبية ملحوظة
لا تدوم عادة أكثر
من 24-36 ساعة ، هل تقلق
بشأنها  تأثير هذا اللقاح عليك
على المدى الطويل لقد فكرت
فيه كثيرًا والشيء الوحيد الذي أعطاني بعضًا
هو محاولة البحث
عن Actua  يحاول اللقاح فهم
كيفية عمل لقاحات mrna ،
ونحن نتفهم هذا بالتأكيد لا يمكنك
الإصابة
من هذا اللقاح لأن اللقاح
لا يحتوي في الواقع على الفيروس
، وعلى الرغم من أن هذه اللقاحات جينية ،
فإنها لا
تغير الحمض النووي الخاص بنا و  بقدر ما تذهب هذه الآثار الجانبية ،
فقد تكون هذه علامة جيدة تعني أن
استجابتك المناعية تعمل من
أجلك ، يجب أن تشعر بالرضا عن
ذلك ولا ينبغي أن يكون هناك أي
صعوبة في العودة لتلك
اللقطة الثانية مع العلم
أنك الآن  في وضع أفضل بكثير
لمحاربة هذا الفيروس المروع
في الوقت الحالي ، يتطلع ياسر إلى
موعده التالي
الذي سيكون في العاشر من كانون الأول (ديسمبر) ، وهو اليوم المحدد
الذي
قد تصرح فيه إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير بأول لقاح لـ
covid19 ،
لذلك قمت بتدوين اسمي لأنني
شعرت بذلك للتو  لا حول لها ولا قوة ،
إنها خدمة عامة أه يجب أن أفعل ذلك
لأنني أعتقد أن التطعيم باستخدام المهارات الجماعية هو حقًا
الطريقة الواقعية الوحيدة للخروج من الوباء الذي
قدمنا تقريرًا عن الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا سي إن إن